Speaker 1: Couple more clips to play for you.
Two days ago, I told you that Mypillow Mike
Lindell's phone was seized by the FBI. A phone
is a type of machine.
Speaker 2: We're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines.
Speaker 1: Yesterday, we looked at the search
warrant for pillow and all of the things that
were on the search warrant. And then today,
I just have a few clips for you of Mike Pillow
really off the rails now after this FBI seizure.
Take a look at this. Here he is on Steve Bannon's
show.
Speaker 2: I told the FBI guys, Steve, I told
the FBI guys, they said, you guys are going
to be on my 6:00 show on frank speech. And
and they said this corrupt investigation,
whatever you're trying to do, and they go,
Mike, we're just doing our jobs. I said, Yeah.
I said, the corruption aspect of our government.
Hold on, hold on, hold on. Stop, stop, stop,
stop, stop, stop.
Speaker 3: I want all the FBI people out there.
We got whistleblowers all over the place.
That phrase is not going to save you. That's
what the Waffen SS said. That's what the Gestapo
said to save themselves after 1945.
Speaker 1: Oh, dear. They claim to be tough
on crime, and yet they have no problem calling
law enforcement Nazis. That's essentially
what Bannon is saying. He's saying, Oh, yeah,
the FBI is saying the same thing that that
Nazis were saying after World War Two. One
other clip here about the cell phone.
Speaker 2: Well, anyway, then he says, here
it comes. He goes, well, after about 25 minutes
of talk and he goes, Mike, we have to take
your cell phone.
Speaker 1: By the way, this is from a different
interview with Charlie Kirk.
Speaker 2: And I go, You're not yet my cell
phone. I said, I'd rather be arrested. I said,
Arrest me. You're not get my phone. I don't
you I don't use a computer. This is all of
my this is my by.
Speaker 1: The way, what do you think happens
to the phone if you get arrested? If you get
arrested, they take all the stuff that's in
your pockets.
Speaker 2: I businesses my window recovery
network this is my thousands of employees
that I I said they were like we all rely on
this. So what would you need my phone for?
And you can't have my phone. He goes, Well,
we got a subpoena right here for your phone
signed by a judge. And I'm going, okay, I'm
going to call can I call my attorney? Ah,
one of my insurance. He goes, No. And he goes,
he goes, I said, I can't call my attorney.
And you think I'm going to give you my phone?
If I don't give you my phone, am I going to
be arrested? He said, no, but we are going
to take the phone. I said, Well, I want to
call. My attorney finally says, You call your
attorney. My attorney, one of my attorneys
gets out there. He goes, Mike, just give him
the phone. And I said, I would rather get
arrested. I said, Everybody relies on this.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Anyway, he doesn't seem to realize
that they take your phone if you get arrested
too. And then lastly, Pillow says that at
a Trump rally this weekend, he is going to
address everything in some.
Speaker 2: Way be with the at the president
our real presidents rally in Ohio on Saturday.
I'm going to speak there about this. We go
now. We have a unique opportunity, everybody,
to spread the word, get the word out. Maybe,
maybe, Steve, that just wants that the media
would go, hey, Mike, why why did they do this
to you? Could it be because they have all
the evidence? Because I want to get rid of
voting machines and electronic computers in
our elections.
Speaker 1: That's what it.
Speaker 2: Is. We're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines anyway.
Speaker 1: So pillow completely. His brain
broke as a result of this seizure. And we'll
see what is going on next week with it. Truly
incredible stuff. Monday 919. It is membership
promo day last chance. Get on my newsletter
at David Pakman dot com to get notified Monday
of this beautiful membership special. The
David Pakman Show is a community and viewer
and listener supported program. I would love
for you to sign up at join dot com. You'll
get the world famous bonus show every single
weekday as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show. You'll get The
Daily Show hours before everybody else gets
it, and you also will be invited to the world
famous members only town halls, the last of
which we had about a week and a half ago,
which was really great.